sehr cooler Typ auf jeden Fall geht's
jetzt für mich zurück nach Deutschland
ich freue mich sehr ich fliege mit Katar
Airways bis es Glas zum ersten Mal in
meinem Leben also wirklich Langstrecke
und das gute ist wirklich bekannt für
die beste Business Class der Welt da
soll es richtig abgehen
kann man das so sagen keine Ahnung wir
checken jetzt erstmal ein dann geht's in
die Lounge dann fliege erstmal nach Doha
steigt da um und dann geht's von Doha
mitten in der Nacht heute nach Frankfurt
zurück insgesamt bin ich über 15 Stunden
unterwegs aber ich habe Bock ich denke
es wird eine geile Reise und richtig
coole Erfahrung für mich auf geht's ach
so und mein Kollege der auch mit mir so
unterwegs war der versucht jetzt von
hier nach Vietnam zu fliegen und möchte
noch ein Ticket kaufen mal gucken ob das
klappt
eine riesen Stress
[Applaus]
so passport control mal gucken ob ich
wieder ausreißen darf oder ob die mich
lieber hier behalten wollen für mich
geht's auf jeden Fall erstmal in die
Katar Airways Premium Lounge die ist
relativ neu gibt es seit 2019 und soll
wohl richtig gut sein ist für Busfahrt
und fast glasgäste ich bin echt mal
gespannt
[Applaus]
so Leute ich bin wieder alleine wir
waren jetzt zwei Wochen zusammen
unterwegs war auf jeden Fall eine
richtig geile Zeit für mich geht's nach
Deutschland zurück er bleibt noch hier
und wir gehen jetzt erstmal hier rein
Katar airway
ich bin gespannt
sondern Abrennen in die Lounge ich muss
sagen das ist doch die größte in der ich
hier war bis jetzt ich wurde allerdings
auch erstmal direkt in den Essensbereich
gesetzt und konnte schön was essen
Sweatshirt
also auf jeden Fall die beste Lounge in
der ich hier war kann ich jetzt schon
sagen aber ich hatte jetzt auch noch
nicht so viele krasse hinter mir ist
Buffet wenn ich euch hier ein paar
Aufnahmen von einem das Befehl war echt
riesig das hier ist zum Beispiel time
massam Curry ich hoffe ich habe es
richtig ausgesprochen hier hatten wir
dann irgendwie Kartoffeln Gemüse und da
links waren dann noch so ein bisschen
Rinderfilet Medaillons und auch die
Auswahl des Desserts wirklich riesig ich
habe versucht alles zu probieren aber
das geht natürlich nicht sonst ist man
direkt voll gegessen ja auch noch
Vorspeisen Suppen und keine Salate und
so weiter also wirklich unfassbar geil
ich kann aber sogar allergart einscannen
und essen was machen wir jetzt mal also
so sieht die Karte aus okay Frühstück
kann man nicht mehr für mich Sushi schön
schön lecker an dann werde ich mir wohl
Sushi bestellen und das sind die
Getränke Alkohol natürlich auch aber
brauche ich jetzt noch nicht mich gibt's
auf jeden Fall erst mal Rinderfilet mega
Jungs mit Paprika und Kartoffeln also
nur ein kleiner vorspeisengang sage ich
mal ich glaube auch ich werde in den
nächsten 15 Stunden so viel essen wie
noch nie zuvor in meinem Leben
boah ich hatte jetzt noch übelst lange
nicht so essen man guckt hier übrigens
in so einem Garten in die Mitte vom
Flughafen eigentlich nice Ausblick
werden hier nicht diese fetten Beton
Dinger okay nächste Runde weiter geht's
mit Sushi ich habe jetzt leider nur zwei
Stücke bestellt war ein kleines
Missverständnis aber egal
wow Hammer ich schwöre ich habe noch nie
besseres Sushi gegessen also ist
unfassbar gut
also eigentlich hatte ich eingeplant
drei Stunden hier in der Lounge zu
verbringen leider hat mein Flug jetzt
direkt schon einen Stunde Verspätung
also muss ich noch ein bisschen zeitlos
sagen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
arbeiten und Kaffee trinken und später
als ich dann noch was so sieht übrigens
die Toilette aus hier in der Lounge gut
man muss sagen auch die First Class
gäste sind hier drin komplett geistig
andere Welt für mich habe ich noch nie
erlebt und dann gibt's auch eine Lounge
die soll nur noch besser sein da hätte
ich auch noch für 120 € ein Update
buchen können in die First Class Lounge
in Doha das ist wohl so der absolute
Überschrift besser geht nicht keine
Ahnung was da noch besser ist als hier
aber ich gehe jetzt erstmal auf Klo das
hier war dann so er der der Chill oder
Arbeitsbereich der Lounge aber auch
wirklich ziemlich groß hier gab es dann
Kaffee Plätzchen irgendwelche Säfte also
auch wirklich super viel Auswahl hier
wird denke ich auch noch mal deutlich
wie groß das eigentlich alles ist wobei
es natürlich auch noch viel größere
Lounge gibt und ja ich habe mich dann
noch mal den ersten Bereich gesetzt eine
Kleinigkeit gegessen dann gab es zum
Abschluss noch ein letztes
thailändisches Bier und ab zum Bording
okay Leute das war doch bis jetzt mal
ein sehr entspannter Aufenthalt jetzt
geht's zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben
auf ein Langstreckenflug Business Class
geil kurz noch zur Info die Business
Class bei Katha Airways sieht nicht
immer gleich aus von Bangkok nach Doha
bin ich geflogen im Airbus A380 hier hat
man natürlich schon ein ziemlich hohen
Komfort das maximale Komfort und Luxus
Erlebnis bietet allerdings die cool
sweet und diese habe ich
glücklicherweise erwischt in einer
Boeing 777 von Doha nach Frankfurt das
ist also eigentlich das Highlight meiner
Reise am Geld habe ich dann festgestellt
dass ich mit meiner mobilen Bordkarte
gar nicht reinkomme deswegen musste ich
noch mal zu einem anderen kleinen
Schalter und dort wird mir dann einen
physischer Boarding Pass aufgestellt war
ich um ehrlich zu sein ein bisschen
überrascht aber gut keine Ahnung warum
das so ist ab ins Flugzeug
[Musik]
hier jetzt ein bisschen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie man hier sehen kann ich war erstmal
ein bisschen über humpelt dass so viele
Leute gleichzeitig mit irgendwas
servieren wollten es gab einen
Champagner und dann haben wir auch
direkt Bangkok verlassen
okay Leute wir verlassen jetzt Bangkok
es war eine sehr nice und für mich
deswegen bin ich natürlich auch ein
bisschen traurig aber auch gestern nach
Hause wie kann man sogar die
Frontansicht sehen gefilmt von einem
Taschenrechner äh nee keine Ahnung kein
Spaß wobei es wirklich sehr unscharf ist
ich habe dann erstmal ein bisschen mein
Platz inspiziert und geschaut was ist da
so alles gibt es gab so ein Kit da war
dann eine face Lotion eine Handlotion
und dieses Tuch drin das habe ich mir
erstmal ins Gesicht geballert dann ging
es aber auch schon los mit dem Essen das
wurde serviert mit so einem candle
lightlicht hier noch mal schön eincremig
vergessen na ja auf jeden Fall gab es
Brötchen mit ein paar Tipps dann so ein
kleines Gruß aus der Küche mäßige Dingen
was mir jetzt nicht so geschmeckt hat
und hier eine Pilzsuppe die war echt
lecker muss ich sagen hat mir sehr gut
geschmeckt und dann geht's weiter mit
Brot verschiedenen hum Sorten und ja das
war eigentlich ganz lecker ein Weinchen
habe ich mir auch noch dazu bestellt und
war eigentlich nach diesen drei Gängen
sag ich mal auch schon gut gesättigt
dann kam erst der Hauptgang das war
chicken mit Reis war auch ganz lecker
und dann habe ich allerdings schon
begonnen mich in die Parkposition nee
Schlafposition zu bewegen ich hatte auch
noch so ein Set bekommen mit
Schlafanzügen das habe ich aber hier
noch nicht verwendet weil ich bin ja
auch relativ schnell dann gelandet
boah gerade aufgewacht ey boah wir
landen jetzt schon sechs Stunden
unterwegs 93 ja super
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und hier kann man dann auch schon die
Nachtlichter von Doha sehen ich hatte
mir unfassbar gerne die Stadt angeguckt
ging natürlich nicht aber ich werde das
Safe mal hinreisen und ich habe dann
auch so langsam realisiert dass ich mich
durch meine Verspätung jetzt echt ins
Zeug legen muss ich hatte nämlich
maximal 40 Minuten umstiegszeit
okay Leute angekommen in Doha ich habe
ungefähr eine Stunde Verspätung habe
jetzt hier noch ein Aufenthalt von
gerade mal einer weiteren Schulen dann
ist schon Boarding mein Flug nach
Frankfurt ich habe keine Ahnung wo ich
muss ich schaue jetzt mal dass ich in
diese Lounge komme weil das soll wohl
die beste sein es gibt noch eine bessere
das ist dann die First das Lounge da tut
sich aber wohl nicht viel und dann
geht's weiter nach Frankfurt in der
Cruise Suite der beste Stars sieht der
Welt da freue ich mich drauf ich hatte
leider absolut keine Zeit wenn die
Lounge zu gehen Boarding war bereits
gestartet und ich dachte mir kommen
nichts riskieren ich will nach Hause
okay Leute ich habe einfach schon
Boarding und ich muss aber zu 10:39 Uhr
bin gerade mal bei C7 also das sind
bestimmt
1,5 km umgelogen also ich hatte nicht
gedacht dass es so groß ist hier ich
habe dann das Geld gefunden als Business
Class Passagier konnte ich auch direkt
durchgehen und für die Business
classreisen gab es ein extra Bus der hat
einfach ein bisschen mehr Komfort
braucht man jetzt nicht unbedingt aber
war ganz angenehm da habe ich mich
hingesetzt aber ich schwöre dieser Bus
hatte höchstens zehn Grad damit sind wir
dann zum Flugzeug gefahren und
eingestiegen wir waren noch die
allererste im Flugzeug gut ob die First
das gestern schon drin waren weiß ich
nicht aber es war ganz entspannt gemacht
[Musik]
okay Leute ich bin drin sieht 6b
können dass ich das Flugzeug noch
spontan ändert das kommt öfter mal
vorbei Karte Airways und dann hatte ich
diese coole sweet halt nicht bekommen
das wäre ein bisschen schade gewesen
aber alles gut gegangen tschüss
bis fast sieht den es gibt
Katar Airways durch meine schon lange
Reisezeit und das Rennen gerade am
Flughafen war ich echt durchgeschwitzt
also schnell mal umziehen unter den
Katar Airways Schlafanzug schmeißen
zwei Wochen diese Klimaanlage überall
hier auch jetzt wieder killen einfach
ich bin eben schon nach dem dritten Gang
abgekackt und konnte nicht mehr und hier
gibt's jetzt einfach wieder so viele
Sachen
ich weiß gar nicht richtig
Sandwich und wahrscheinlich gibt es
morgen früh auch noch frühstücken
hinterher ich muss auch sagen ich habe
jetzt 1.700 € bezahlt für alles zusammen
30 absolut in Ordnung also für den
Service und das gesamte so kann man auf
jeden Fall nichts sagen
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall sehr kurzer Aufenthalt
hier leider ich hätte mir gern die
Lounge angeschaut
[Musik]
wer hätte es gedacht ging es dann auch
schon weiter mit dem Essen es gab noch
mal eine Kürbiscremesuppe die war
wirklich lecker dazu gab es Sushi und
auch noch mal die Brötchen wie schon
beim ersten Flug das habe ich erstmal
schön gegessen und muss sagen in der Kuh
sweet hat man noch mal mehr Platz es ist
wirklich quasi eine eigene Kabine und
ich konnte mich wirklich sehr relax
zurücklegen habe auch noch einen Film
geguckt aber bin dann auch Zeit da
eingeschlafen so dass wir mein Hauptgang
erst am nächsten Morgen serviert wurde
hier noch ein paar Sachen die man
geschenkt bekommt wieder irgendwelche
bodycremes dann so ein Travel Kit mit
Schlafmaske und so weiter und so fort
vieles kann man davon gebrauchen vieles
braucht man auch nicht okay Leute ich
habe das vergessen
[Musik]
und so geil sah das Frühstück aus
wirklich traumhaft dazu ein Blick aus
dem Fenster über die Wolken mit
Landeanflug auf Frankfurt so kann man
auf jeden Fall frühstücken das war echt
ein sehr sehr entspannter morgen für
mich
[Musik]
okay Leute nach über 15 Stunden
angekommen in Frankfurt war ein sehr
entspannter nicer Flug ich bin fast
ausgeschlafen besser geht's eigentlich
nicht okay Leute wie man sehen kann ich
bin wieder heil zu Hause angekommen bin
jetzt gerade hier in meinem Büro bin
jetzt auch schon wieder 5 Tage in
Deutschland musste erstmal ein bisschen
klar kommen ich bin tatsächlich immer
noch krank es fuckt mich so ab ich
glaube die Klimaanlage in zwei Flugzeuge
hat noch mal schön dazu beigetragen
trotzdem muss ich sagen ich habe die
Katar Airways Business Class sehr
genossen ich habe mich sehr wohl gefühlt
es wird sich herrlich um mich gekümmert
so angenehm bin ich doch nie gereist das
Essen war fast immer hervorragend das
hat mir sehr sehr gut geschmeckt und ich
bin mal gespannt ob in Zukunft
irgendeine Business Class das noch
toppen kann Emirate soll natürlich auch
sehr sehr gut sein das werde ich in
naher Zukunft wenn ich halt die
Möglichkeit dazu habe mein abchecken ich
hoffe das Video hat euch gefallen und
ihr habt Bock auf mehr dann abonniert
super gerne den Kanal ihr könnt mir auch
gerne auf Instagram folgen da bekommt
ihr dann solche Sachen immer viel mit
vielen vielen Dank fürs zuschauen Leute
haut rein wir sehen uns ciao